بسم الله الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله
صاحب السموم الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس المجلس الوزراء
مملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه رئيس
الدور الثاني والثلاثين لمجلس جامعه
العربيه على مستوى القمه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو ملوك ورؤساء الدول
العربيه معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيث امين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه اصحاب المعالي
والسعاده رؤوسا رؤساء الوفود المشاركه
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته وبعد ايها الاخوه الاعزاء
يشرفني ان اتقدم بخالص الشكر والتقدير
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه ملكا
وحكومه وشعبا على كرم ضيافه وحسن
الاستقبال منذ وصولنا الى بلد الحرمين
الشريفين ويساعدني ان
عن خالص الشكر والتقدير لاخي فقامه الرئيس
عبد المجيد تبون رئيس جمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه الشقيقه رئيس الدوله
السابقه لمجلس جامعه العربيه على مستوى
القمه
ونطمنوا من جهود كبير ساهمت في
تسيير اجتماعاتنا ومتابعه قضايانا العربيه
كما اوجه التهنئه الحاره على صاحب السمو
الملك الملك الملك الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس المجلس
الوزراء المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
رئيس الدوره الثاني والثلاثون لمجلس
الجامعه العربيه على مستوى القمه متمنيا
لقياده النجاح والتوفيق في هذه الدوره
التي نتمنى ان تحقق اهدافنا المنشوده
وتعالج قضايانا فيما يعز اعمالنا العربيه
المشترك
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والصمود يطيب لي عن
اعرب عن سعادتي وسعاده الشعب الصومال
لعوده الجمهوريه السوريه العربيه الشقيقه
الى جامعه العربيه لتمارس دورها التاريخي
في مختلف القضايا العربيه
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والسمو
في شان السودان ندرك جميعا ان الاشتباكات
الاخيره بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع امر
مؤلم ومحزن وتضم منا جميعا بدر كافه
الجهود من اجل وضع الجد لهذه الاحداث التي
تحول دون تحقق ما يتطلع او الشعب السوداني
من الامن والاستقرار والازدهاد
ونحن نثمن كافه الجهود المبدله لاجل ذلك
سواء من الجهات الدوليه والاقليميه
والعربيه ونقص بالذكر جهود المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه والولايات
المتحده والتي كللت بعقد لقاءات بين
الطرفين وامراض اتفاق اتفاقيه هدنه املين
ان ينجح اشقاء السودانيون
في وصول اتفاق السلام دائما ينسى اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسموم اننا في الصومال
منذ تولينا قياده البلاد
في في نصف العام وتامين العاصمه من
تفجيرات وعمليات الاغتيال ولا تزال قواتنا
المصلحه وجلسه الامنيه تقول حربا على مدار
الساعه ونامل في غضون عام من الان للصومال
خال من حركه الشباب الاعرابي الارهابي
ثالثا
انسحاب قوات الاتحاد الافريقيه ولايه
اتحاد قوات قوه اتحاد الافريقيه تنتهي في
ديسمبر من عام 2024
ستتمكن القوات الصوماليه من القيام
بالمهام الامنيه قبل هذه التاريخ
ثالثا العفاء عن الديون حيث ابرمت البلاد
اتفاقيه الاعفاء من الديون مع مؤسسات
الدوليه
وتمكنا من تنفيذ كافه المتطلبات وشروط
المطلوبه وانا استعمال الرحله الاعفاء من
الديون قبل نهايه العام الحالي
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه وفي الختام نجدد
عزمنا على بدر كل الجهود لخدمه قضايانا
لخدمه قضايا بلداننا
عن عملنا المشترك من التشارك والتشاور
وندعو الله ان يوفقنا لما فيه خير لامتنا
وان يسدد جهودنا التجاوز الاوضاع
الاستثنائيه التي يعيشها وطننا العربي بما
يعزز
ام امننا واستقرارنا ويحق ما يتضاع اليه
شعوبنا من الازدهار والرقاب واخيرا اقرر
الشكر الاخ صاحب السمو الرئيس المجلس
الجلسه ومعالي الاخرين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه وكلوا الحاضرين في
هذه الاجتماع الهام
ودمتم في عون الله وحفظه والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
طبعت المزيد من
الاخبار قصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات